foreign
folks welcome to the Dark Horse podcast
live stream without even looking I can
tell you it's episode 151 and that's
about as far as I've gotten with the uh
the relevant question have you um have
you thought about it
it is episode 151 you were Dr Brett
Weinstein I am Dr Heather Hein and Zach
is Zach is saying that he cannot hear
can you hear me
all right well it is episode 151 we are
here at the Dark Horse uh temporary
permanent temporary permanent temporary
Studio I think
and uh while the uh the original host
main host is getting his audio working I
will just walk us through
a few other things we are going to do a
q a today unlike uh what we have done
for the last couple of weeks we
apologize for the tech problems uh so we
have a lot of questions already queued
up but we will accept more questions as
well you can ask those at
darkhorseimmissions.com and tomorrow we
are actually doing two more live streams
so four live streams this weekend it is
November 26th the Saturday after
Thanksgiving as American Thanksgiving as
I'm speaking tomorrow Sunday November
27th at 9 45 Pacific time we're going to
do a short one hour holiday gift live
stream and talk some about
uh about things like that and as if On
Cue actually On Cue more or less we're
going to talk about uh many wonderful
things including this fabulous object
that was sent to us by a good friend uh
a marvelous gift and anyway you will
find out more about it tomorrow both the
object and the friend Erica uh the
friend is a gift
as far as I'm concerned frankly to
planet Earth but we can't gift him to
others I wouldn't even try yeah yeah
so that my computer has decided to go to
sleep apparently we're boring it
um we're gonna do that tomorrow at 9 45
Pacific and then at 11 A.M Pacific as
always on the last Sunday of the month
although December we're gonna switch it
up a little bit because that would make
it Christmas we do our private q a which
you can get access to through my patreon
so those are a lot of fun they really
have a very different tenor
than the public q and A's that we do in
part because the audience is so much
smaller that we're actually able to
watch and interact with the chat and
answer you know and address things that
come up in the chat in real time which
is which is wonderful so this is the
first of four live streams for us your
hosts of Dark Horse this week uh should
I just keep talking now that your
audio's back uh no I just uh I'm I'm now
joining the chat which is the chat well
that's how the kids say it so and so has
now joined the chat Dr Freud has now
joined the chat at the point somebody
makes an embarrassing linguistic error
that
suggest something Floridian I see so
anyway yes I've joined the chat uh sorry
about that little hiccup with the uh the
audio but uh here we are no worries uh
the chat the actual chat not the one
that Brett has joined is live on Odyssey
or Dr Freud um I I can't speak to that
I'm not on honestly at the moment I have
not seen checked whether or not Dr Freud
is or is not there there's presumably
someone alive right now who is
legitimately a doctor Freud maybe
they're an odyssey I don't know
how could we know uh this week at
Natural Selections which is where I
write uh I have a piece called on hate
crimes and child abuse and it's
responsive to the Club Q Massacre
outside of Colorado Springs this week
at Club Q which is
denominated as an lgbtq nightclub and
specifically about the response by some
in the media that this was an inevitable
thing to have happened given that there
are people out there who critique taking
children to drag shows and giving them
puberty blockers
that is an extraordinary and despicable
claim and I write about that some in
Natural Selections this week and that is
that kind of thinking is related to a
lot of what uh you were going to be
steering us through this week I believe
yeah yeah uh yeah we will talk in depth
but how one puzzles through these these
difficult questions is really uh the
core the core of the matter yeah I will
say
um this is of absolutely no importance
really to anyone and of no relevance at
all anyone just listening but I'm stuck
with my low rent laptops fan this week
and uh that's it it's just dumb it's
just a dumb laptop stance way too big
doesn't really sit on me very well
anyway
um I'm not pleased with it either I
expect I will hear from some of you who
aren't because that's the kind of thing
that some people comment on
um it's already antagonizing me
okay we have a new store as we've talked
about the last several weeks it's
terrific it's a small operation run by a
couple who um they both have the print
shop where they make uh the merchandise
and they also run the store itself and
it's at
darkhorsestore.org and you can find all
sorts of cool stuff well I'm sure we'll
mention that again tomorrow with regard
to the holiday gift episode but you can
get do not comply do not affirm shirts
you can get lie to a tyrant Dark Horse
straight up Dark Horse stuff uh it's
it's pretty great
and uh by way of finishing up
announcements and sort of General
Logistics we are supported by you our
audience we are grateful to you uh we
appreciate you subscribing to the
channel the main channel the clips
Channel at Star course podcast Clips on
either YouTube or Odyssey uh and liking
and sharing both full episodes and clips
wherever you watch or listen Spotify
Apple podcast anywhere and uh just a
reminder that even if you're seeing ads
that are not being read by us on YouTube
that doesn't mean that we are in the
good graces of YouTube nope certainly
not they are putting ads on our content
and making money off of us but not
sharing any of that with us so they
demonetized us for
um being really truly awful people and
apparently since we have not seen the
wisdom of our ways they have decided not
to remonetize us yes yes my
interpretation was a little different
about oh who was truly awful but uh you
know anyway we can we can agree to
disagree about that and have no other
choice okay oh no I I think actually I
agree with you oh no no you and I are
not agreeing to disagree
I am agreeing to disagree with YouTube
because they have left me exactly zero
other options right yes yes
um okay okay you can join uh either of
our patreons as I mentioned uh next week
before well since we're gonna have a lot
more live streams this week it won't be
before you have a chance to see us again
but before next week's live stream we
will uh Brett will have one of his
patreon conversations and tomorrow we
have the private q a which is on mine uh
we encourage you to join it and also on
uh either of our patreon to get access
to the Discord server where you can meet
uh a wide range of people and engage in
honest conversations about difficult
topics have uh karaoke nights uh book
club young or old left or right there's
a spot for you at the campfire okay we
also do have sponsors and we are
grateful to them we only take sponsors
uh who make products or offer services
that we ourselves can directly and have
directly assessed and decide or high
quality or any couple of uh cases as in
one of today's uh sponsors we have a
close friend who can directly assess and
has said yes this is this is worthy of
Your sponsorship so without further Ado
we have our three sponsors for this week
the first is seed
seed is a company focused on bacteria
and the microbiome and they have a
terrific probiotic called ds01 daily
synbiotic that's syn biotic I always
prefer eating real food to taking pills
but I have to say I really love this
product there are a lot of things that
you can do to enhance your health and we
talk about uh many of them here in Dark
Horse and our sign off includes three of
them we go to the ones you love eat good
food and get outside but a lot is hidden
in those words what for instance
constitutes good food good food is real
food whole food food that has been alive
recently and was grown with care and
conditions as ancient as possible given
the constraints of the 21st century but
even many people who eat such a diet are
missing something
we contain multitudes every individual
human contains so many other organisms
some of which may harm us but many of
which exist with us in harmony we need
them this is why probiotics can be an
important tool in a healthy lifestyle
even if you eat nutrient dense food and
avoid processed foods and sugar as if On
Cue our other cat has shown up looking
for nutrient dense food
that said probiotics are kind of the new
current thing everyone's taking them or
thinking of taking them it can seem like
maybe it's just a fad good news though
seeds ds01 daily symbiotic is the real
deal
not all probiotics are created equally
seeds dsl1 daily symbiotics a broad
spectrum two in one probiotic and
Prebiotic it contains 24 distinct
probiotic strains in a two in one
capsule that protects the probiotics
until they hit the colon where they are
most effective
if you've taken a probiotic before and
never felt a difference it's likely
because the good bacteria weren't
surviving your GI tract GI tract seed is
designed differently that's why it works
seeds daily symbiotic supports gut skin
and heart health and micronutrient
synthesis many who have used seed report
improvements to their to their digestive
function in 24 to 48 hours start a new
healthy habit today visit seed.com
Darkhorse and use code Darkhorse to
redeem 20 off your first month of seeds
ds01 daily symbiotic that's seed.com
s-e-d just like it sounds slash
Darkhorse and use code Darkhorse at
checkout
our program is also brought to you our
second sponsor today is Seoul s-o-l-e a
sustainable Orthopedic footwear company
Seoul is one of our two Footwear
sponsors and we love them both they're
quite
uh
they are quite different from one
another yet both have an evolutionary
approach to creating shoes that help
feet get and stay healthy and people
become more mobile
Soul intentionally brings structure back
with both their shoes and their footbeds
so aims with its Footwear to return our
feet to health and the shoes by so are
beautiful I've been wearing pool of
Seoul a pair of Soul districts a low
zipped short boot and camel colored
vegetable tan suede leather and I love
them so footbeds are the industry
standard and over-the-counter supportive
insoles and inserts they are moldable
for custom comfort giving you all the
benefits of personalized support at a
fraction of the price of orthotics sole
footbeds which are made from recycled
cork include a signature support of arch
which is clinically proven to reduce
Arch strain in your feet up to 34 this
is especially effective in helping
recovery recovery from plantar fasciitis
which affects more than 2 million
Americans along with a range of other
ailments from Shin's plants to hip knee
and back pain
sofa beds also promote neutral alignment
and good posture and are particularly
effective at preventing fatigue when
standing for long hours on hard surfaces
Seoul is on a mission to end foot pain
in North America so they are sending a
free footbed to every zip code on the
continent Dark Horse listeners should
visit yoursoul.com Darkhorse and if you
live in a zip code or in the U.S or
postal code in Canada where Seoul hasn't
shipped you'll receive a free
performance medium footbed they believe
in the quality of their product so much
that they are sure that once you feel
the Comfort pain relief performance
enhancement and injury prevention
benefits of sole footbeds you'll want
them in every shoe you own
simply enter your ZIP code or postal
code in the shipping section at checked
out checkout to stand a chance to get a
totally free footbed while supplies last
if your footbed isn't free because solar
is already shipped to your zip you can
still get 50 off by entering Dark Horse
50 at checkout so far Seoul has shipped
to 38 of the 41 000 ZIP codes in the US
they've got a lot of giving to do
help push those percentages by visiting
yoursoul.com Darkhorse today
our final sponsor this week is MD
hearing aid MD hearing aid makes high
quality effective hearing aids for a
tiny fraction of what most hearing aids
cost and you can buy directly from them
MD hearing aid was founded by an ENT
surgeon who made it his mission to
develop a quality hearing aid that
anyone could afford most people who need
hearing aids only require a few settings
so he removed several of the less often
needed components and he cut out the
middleman MD hearing aid has sold over a
million units and over uh and has a 45
risk risk-free 45-day risk-free trial
and money back guarantee that's what it
says on the paper
these hearing aids aim to fit so well
that no one will know you're wearing
them the rechargeable batteries last up
to 30 hours their volt plus model is
water resistant in up to three feet of
water and you don't need a prescription
to get one you buy it directly from the
source where audiologists and licensed
hearing Specialists are available seven
days a week everyone can empathize with
what it feels like to be left out of a
conversation that others are enjoying
here's a testimonial from a friend of
ours who has substantial hearing loss
and who relies on hearing aids we asked
her to try this product and here's what
she said quote with my particular type
of hearing loss a deep male voice in a
noisy room is the hardest situation for
me to hear and understand speech I wore
the MD hearing aid to have a
conversation with a deep voiced man in a
room with a lot of white noise the MD
hearing aid passed the test as my
conversations partner's voice was clear
and understandable
at a price point of under a thousand
dollars I was amazed at how effective
they are
MD hearing aid is bringing affordable
hearing to hundreds of thousands of
people people who might not otherwise be
able to afford high quality hearing aids
get Clinic level care for 90 percent
less with MD hearing aid go to
mdhearingaid.com and use the promo code
Darkhorse to get their new buy one get
one deal a pair of hearing aids costs
just 149.99 plus Dark Horse listeners
receive a free extra charge case a
hundred dollar value so head to
mdhearingaid.com and use promo code
Darkhorse to get their new buy one get
one deal a pair of hearing aids for only
149.99
all right
that's our sponsors for the day
that is our Logistics and our background
and um
here we are here we have November 2022.
Right Time Marches on time I don't know
if you've noticed that Time Marches On
two and three quarters years
into the public becoming aware of coven
yes
now I wanted to talk about something
that's a little bit delicate this week I
wanted to talk about the apparent exit
from Twitter of Claire Lehman and Sam
Harris and uh I don't want to talk about
it because I think it's especially
important to talk about those two and
whatever choice they have made and the
reasons they have made it but I do think
that their trajectory over covet
actually gives us reason to reflect on
why the intellectual landscape broke
apart in the way that it did
but before doing that I do want to say
I'm both Sam and Claire have been as
many people have pointed out quite
terrible to us over the course of covet
and so just for the uninitiated
um
who are they yeah all right Sam Harris
as many will know is primarily I would
say a philosopher by training he's a
neurobiologist
um or at least that's what he uh studied
in graduate school he hasn't uh been a
functioning academic after his degree as
far as I know but in any case he's a
prolific author he's written on many
important questions including questions
of Free Will he's written a very famous
book on
um lying that is in fact a title of the
book about the harm that is done to
Civilization by lying being a normal
process and argue that has effectively
never
Justified
um anyway he's also a friend and a
member of what was Loosely termed the
intellectual dark web
um Claire Lehman is the founder of
Colette which is an online magazine that
was
uh also affiliated with the intellectual
dark web it was a very vibrant outlet
for heterodox content and during the uh
the height of the battles over
wokeness and the public sphere so it was
a a a I think it was founded in 2016 and
but when we became aware of it in 2017
it was ascending rapidly I think it was
founded in 2015 doesn't really matter
somewhere in that neighborhood but in
any case Claire is the the founder and
the editor-in-chief of Colette
and so this week Sam uh exited
Twitter after
it was we of course those of us who have
not talked to Sam don't know exactly why
why he exited it is clear that it was
his decision to do it he was not thrown
off of Twitter
um but he left after a
brief back and forth over the question
of musk Elon Musk returning uh Trump's
account to functionality on Twitter now
as far as I know Trump has not tweeted
but his account is restored
and Sam's Point which is consistent with
things Sam has been saying for uh many
years was that Trump is such a grave
threat to democracy and civilization
that
um musk should not allow him back on and
this is obviously in conflict with
musk's stated objective to make a Public
Square in which a wide variety of
viewpoints are allowed and
um
so that's the long and short of it after
Sam left Twitter shortly after Claire uh
also inactivated her account and these
are just they're not these accounts
appear to be deleted and my
understanding is
that their owners have something like 30
days
to reactivate them and they would come
back uh as normal accounts having lost
no functionality or followers or
anything but if they don't reactivate in
30 days they will be uh permanently
invalid
there are a few Washington Post articles
put on the changes of foot at Twitter
that that I want to insert in here at
some point and I don't know
I don't know if this is the moment I
think I think it's not let me say The
Upfront part and then we can come to
what uh what the Washington Post has but
I but I also have some things about your
two your two types of people in the
world so I I don't want to get either of
those those branches lost here yep fair
enough
the first thing I want to say is I don't
think the exit of these people from
Twitter is a good thing as much as I'm
not happy with the way either of them
has behaved towards us over the course
of covet especially
um I think it is a loss to have these
voices not present in what is either
going to be or not going to be a new
Public Square in other words by what
reads like taking their ball and going
home they are robbing Twitter of the
potential to be a place where we restore
the capacity that was once
uh explicitly defended by Sam and
certainly at least implicitly defended
by Claire which is to say a place where
we hash out disagreements honorably
um you know without it being personal
Twitter could become that potentially
but if certain voices decide they won't
be there because there are opinions
being expressed there that they find are
Beyond The Pale then it can't be that
and so
I would say
um
that I certainly hope that with the
clock ticking on those accounts expiring
both of them will reconsider and I would
ask people to be kind to them if they do
come back and and realize that we all
have an interest in a Public Square that
works and we do not want to get in the
habit of driving people
uh from it
all right do you want to say what you uh
wanted to bring to the conversation
about the Washington Post
uh it feels like a much less obvious
place now but I guess I can
um
okay uh
it's your call I mean we can drink some
water first though
I know
uh
okay uh
this is going to feel like a
non-sequitur
um
Taylor Lorenz who is her own cultural
phenomenon
wrote In The Washington Post a few days
ago
uh
pewter won't open it
uh
so now of course I'm having the
technical business third piece about
um
Online safety experts
so you can show my screen now Zach it's
called opening the gates of hell musk
says he will revive banned accounts the
Twitter Chief says he will reinstate
accounts suspended for threats
harassment misinformation beginning next
week
and I just there are a few things to
share from here here's one quote Apple
and Google need to seriously this is a
quote from the piece but it's also a
quote from someone named Alejandra
carabao
Apple and Google need to seriously start
exploring booting Twitter off the app
store said Alejandra carabaio clinical
instructor at Harvard laws Cyber Law
Clinic what musk is doing is
existentially dangerous for various
marginalized communities it's like
opening the gates of hell in terms of
the Havoc it will cause people who
engage in direct targeted harassment can
come back and engage in dachshund
targeted harassment vicious bullying
calls for violence celebration of
violence I can't even begin to State how
dangerous this will be
so that entire paragraph basically is a
quote from this person Alejandra
carabayo who well must be important uh
this person is at Harvard law except
they're not Harvard Law they're at
Harvard Law's Cyber Law clinic and
Alejandra carabao is a trans person uh
who is one of the most bullying and
horrifying people on Twitter and when I
went to uh remind myself of that fact I
found that Alejandra has has blocked me
so you know you can you can always see
what people tweet by not going in as
yourself and so it's possible to see
that this car bio character is indeed
full of sensorious rage and a lack of
recognition of reality and uh there's a
there's a a bunch of claims here by
someone
who who is simply at a an Institute
called the Cyber Law Clinic that exists
somehow within the within
the affiliation of Harvard Law uh who
pull quote was then turned into a
headline for Washington Post
okay so that's that's gives you a sense
of what Washington Post is is
promulgating on the world as the effect
of Elon musk's attempt to restore a lack
of censorship to Twitter scroll down a
little bit more in this piece and you
get
experts say that Bots and Bad actors can
easily skew the results of a Twitter
poll and so basing decisions on what is
irresponsible quote a Twitter poll can
be manipulated there's nothing
scientific or rigorous in any way about
what he's doing
it's true said Sarah T Roberts an
associate professor at UCLA and faculty
director for UCLA's Center for critical
internet inquiry who previously worked
at Twitter research and content
moderation processes
so the two main people
who are being excited in this article
appear to have affiliations with Elite
institutions right it's Harvard and UCLA
and we know how Fairfax sunscreen for
those only only watching and you could
show the full screen now so that people
can enjoy full of fairfaxiness of it all
our epic Tabby oh no
so then he's gone
[Music]
um Sarah T Roberts the associate
professor at UCLA which is more of an
affiliation than a clinical instructor
or whatever caravio is at this cyber
Alliance here at Harvard but the way
that uh Taylor Lorenz has written this
it would appear that Sarah Roberts is an
associate professor of oh I don't know a
real field and uh no it doesn't take
much to discover that actually what
Sarah Roberts is an associate professor
of at UCLA is in fact gender studies
which uh you know you might have
predicted if you had looked at anything
that she has done either in her former
role research and content moderation
processes at Twitter or
uh now uh as an associate professor of
gender studies at UCLA so just one more
thing about actually one more thing
about this and then one other uh one
other article from Washington Post this
week uh Glenn Greenwall nailed this with
his assessment and uh
sorry so much got
closed down I will show here in a moment
uh Zach uh here's just a screenshot shot
a screenshot from Greenwald breaking
allowing those disliked by liberals to
be heard on the internet will literally
kill many people
screaming face emoji uh worn the most
neurotic mentally unwell petulant Petty
tyrants who have declared themselves
Online safety experts and are now called
that by liberal media Outlets he follows
up Taylor irenz miraculously found three
or four people more neurotic clearly
unstable and censorship happy than she
bestowed them with fake expertise titles
and now the Washington Post is blasting
out her alarmist Asylum worthy babbling
to Millions hashtag journalism uh that I
don't know if Greenwell is always that
snarky but that struck me as just
perfect in terms of describing what
actually this is this is one person
who's got a sphere of equally not so
people who don't know reality when it is
right in front of them and Lorenz is
citing her little band of
ridiculous friends and the Washington
Post is putting it across their their
headlines
yeah it's um yeah I don't know that I
would call Greenwald snarky he's very
very sharp this I mean this felt snarky
it's a little snarky but I mean I think
like many of us he has found that no
institution is capable of functioning
and so he is now out here in the wild
west being a journalist and then also
being forced to comment on the
environment instead of just doing
journalism he's now forced to comment on
the environment and what he's pointing
to for anybody who missed it is the idea
that there is an ideology that
absolutely depends on a set of rules
that applies to others and not to them
that is the only way that this ideology
makes its way in the world and so the
point is all of the hand-wringing and
pearl clutching and fainting couch
reaching that is going on
is people who have gotten used to having
the walls have ears and a bias in favor
of their perspective are now not so
interested in living in a world where uh
anything can be said and the platform
cannot be brought down on people's heads
for you know saying that uh there's
evidence that Ivermectin works or
um that you know it's a mistake for us
to encourage or allow children to be
surgically altered because they utter
something that someone takes is an
indication that they will be trans or
something like this yep you need us a
biased environment but I would also just
point out for those who are not paying
close attention to what the Washington
Post is
The Washington Post is a once great
newspaper that is now owned by Jeff
Bezos a direct competitor of Elon Musk I
would assume in many Realms but in one
very clearly he is also running a
private space program so this is
somebody who has a personal ax to grind
potentially and has major contact
contracts with the CIA so there's a
question about what the Washington Post
is and why it takes such an odd
perspective and why it is broadcasting
the opinions of people who clearly don't
have a position from which to say
something meaningful and authoritative
but are being used as pseudo authorities
to you know give the thinnest veneer of
legitimacy to these absurd uh opinions
yes and so anyway that's the environment
we're living in no newspaper Works no
platform Works no University Works no
science journal works and one individual
May and I don't say this with certainty
because I don't know but one individual
may be in the process of attempting to
create a single place that functions in
order to allow a balanced discussion of
things about which we naturally disagree
right yeah go ahead one more piece from
The Washington Post
um with with that frankly necessary
background as to what what it now is
what it
you know it doesn't with a change of
ownership it doesn't come with a change
in the banner right it's still it's
still claims
um that it's
the central message of its being is
democracy dies in darkness yep I believe
I have I haven't actually looked at the
um the Mast Ed a physical Masthead of
the Washington is this an observation or
is that a threat
oh my God yeah uh so that November 24th
by Lorenz that I just quoted
um some of the supposed experts uh that
she's got bolstering you know not
bolstering creating her entire argument
in that piece also cites an earlier
Washington Post piece earlier only by
two days uh which is this one which you
can show my screen I will also point out
that for those of you who've been
watching I didn't point out uh with the
previous one but they're both both of
these pieces are filed under technology
and you've got one of those experts the
gender studies person at UCLA running
some sort of a uh you know internet
information uh thing where you know
these these aren't people I think who
actually understand anything about
technology this is the societal
implications of choices that people who
are running tech companies are making
which is actually totally different from
technology and it's actually the same
error that is being made with regard to
science right you know the stuff that's
being published in nature and science is
actually well we really feel strongly
about out the societal implication of
this thing that might originally have
been found out by science so we're going
to claim that the thing that our
feelings about it wrong though they may
be
um are are the science and and here too
we have you know this
claiming to be Sciences Washington Post
uh November 22nd musk's Free Speech
agenda
dismantle safety work at Twitter
insiders say wait wait wait wait first
of all there's the beautiful insiders
say right which is like fact Checkers
say or scientists say or any one of
these garbage claims but the other thing
is the phrase dismantles safety work
well we're so the first standing I'm not
going to we could spend hours on just
this article yeah just the very first
anecdote that they provide to you know
make it clear to the readers that this
is really happening musk's Free Speech
agenda is dismantling safety work at
Twitter so say the Insiders and they
would know here we go hours after Elon
Musk took control of Twitter in late
October the trust and safety team
responsible for combating hate speech on
the site received an urgent directive
bring back the Babylon bee
to some Twitter employees the order was
troubling the self-described Christian
satirical site had been banned since
March for refusing to delete a tweet
naming Biden Health official Rachel
Levine it's quote Man of the Year
Levine is a transgender woman and this
is not what the Washington Post say but
therefore a man
and the Tweet violated a 2018 rule
prohibiting Twitter usage from targeting
transgender people by referring to them
by the name or gender they used before
transitioning
used before transitioning assigned at
Birth right wrong Washington Post again
well and I would point out that this has
created if you think and I do think that
there is an argument that it is not
decent in the case of somebody who is
actually experiencing gender dysphoria
and makes the decision to transition the
kind thing to do is to treat them as the
gender they aspire to be however this is
this you could still point out reality
and frankly you can still even make fun
of them because we're all allowed to
make fun of people right well that's
just the question and especially these
papers have no standing right the idea
that we are to pretend
um that uh that Chelsea Manning gave
documents to WikiLeaks is in violation
with the facts of History right
um not if you believe that there is a
gender Essence that was inside Jason was
it no no it was this is Bradley Bradley
yes um but no my point is look it's a
goddamn newspaper it has an obligation
to say look there's nothing at odds with
the idea of transitioning to say Bradley
Manning conveyed documents to WikiLeaks
and later transitioned and it now is
known as Chelsea but I feel like is
known as right like I I actually feel
like this is kind of missing the point
here the Babylon bee which is hilarious
if you don't know it uh like you know
look it up and yes it is back on Twitter
now and and and good for it uh made
Rachel Levine I did not find a picture
of Rachel Levine here for you guys but
made Rachel Levine Man of the Year which
is you know
wrong but not because it's calling
Rachel living in a man well because
Rachel Levine is a man uh and Rachel
Levine has actually helped uh destroy a
lot of lives through the trans nonsense
and also now the copen nonsense what the
Levine was like the head health official
in Pennsylvania I think before being
upranked by the Biden Administration to
something something and now gets to wear
military regalia somehow
um but look
I don't want to pretend that we know the
answer to exactly how moderation should
be done and what questions should be
moderated and what questions it's not a
simple issue because there are things
that we don't want on these platforms
Rachel Levine is a public figure Rachel
Levine has a family that she had as a
man and she is now in this role
presenting herselfine is the father of
children is the father of children that
is right and the fact that that is a
difficult sentence to say and have it be
understood is evidence of where we are
it's not the responsibility of the
Babylon being not to notice this and
it's not the responsibility of Twitter
to police it right the point is this is
a perfectly legitimate thing to observe
is interesting ironic funny bizarre it
is all of those things and so anyway
Babylon B is back and you know again the
the hand ringing the Pearl clutching the
feigning couch reaching all of the stuff
that is that is occurring as a result of
it but like Babylon B having been having
had its account taken down in March so
over half a year ago for tweeting that
Rachel Levine wins their Man of the Year
award like that was the offense
they were in Twitter jail for over half
a year for that and and that thing is
the lead anecdote in the Washington Post
evidence that my computer has of course
gone back to sleep so I can't see it
um in their headlined article musk's
Free Speech agenda dismantle safety work
at Twitter insiders say right because
allowing people to see that a satirical
site thinks that Rachel Levine should
get man of the year is dismantling
safety work
right it's just the whole idea of of
invoking safety yeah um and I would
point out a case that we keep uh
referring to but I still think you know
the Babylon bee is back the Dr Roller
Gator account is not the doctor roller
Gator account was suspended in February
for obviously satirically suggesting uh
I believe that Jordan Peterson and
Justin Trudeau uh Avail themselves of
white gloves with which to challenge
each other by slapping each other across
the face and that was determined to be
violence and so what you can see in this
is that the system has been turned into
a partisan with rules that equate satire
with violence and then those rules are
used to exclude people from conversation
which then destroys our ability to
understand even what those in our
community even think because the
conversation is now biased by a set of
rules used to drive certain voices out
by claiming that they were engaged in
violence that they clearly weren't and
so anyway the idea that there is
anything noteworthy about somebody
unhooking those unfair rules and having
no uh built-in bias of the structure
towards one perspective or another the
idea that that is in and of itself
alarming enough to drive people off of
Twitter or to drive the Washington Post
to report multiply on the hellscape that
is apparently being opened up by Free
Speech a a value on which almost all of
us used to agree right is it's quite
something
um all right are you uh where you wanted
to go with
The Washington Post sure
Okay so
my main purpose today was to point out a
dichotomy that I think underlies much of
what we are now seeing
including the uh
loss of people like Sam and Claire from
this discussion
um what I think they would say about why
they've left is that they've been
hounded by people and if you look on
Twitter you will see that the
conventional wisdom about what is true
with respect to things on which they've
both taken very strong positions
has shifted radically and so what I
wanted to talk about is
now that we are almost three years into
the covid phase of History
I want to talk about what happened with
respect to
um
people's intellectual standing and
people's intellectual performance that
there's an interesting pattern that I
think comes down to a single dichotomy
about which we can say a lot of nuanced
things but a single dichotomy that
separates those who ended up uh
severely damaging their reputations
and those who in the end turned out to
be right in spite of what may have been
said about them before now obviously I
believe you and I are in that latter
category where it is increasingly clear
that
um our concerns about the vaccines
or if anything over cautious that uh our
skepticism of their utility was well
placed
that our belief that there are
alternatives that might well have been
applied that weren't being used because
they weren't profitable seems to be
accurate and our argument that this does
not appeal appear to be a natural
pandemic but in fact Downstream of a lab
leak that is in fact linked to some of
the same people who have given us such
bad policy with respect to treating and
controlling the disease that that also
turns out to be well supported by the
evidence so
how the heck did we do it right and why
did so many others fail to including Sam
and Claire
and the point I want to make is that I
think there are really
two approaches to
um clear thinking
and it comes down to
that's really cute
um what uh
does one attempt as is now taught in
graduate school and effectively every
field as far as I can tell does one
attempt to figure out which model is
best and then become expert in applying
it
or does one deploy a model and compare
its results to the emerging evidence and
adjust the model accordingly and move in
the direction of better and better
models right and my claim is going to be
that our entire expert class was doing
the former thing
it was practiced at a game in which it
would identify a model that was claimed
to be the best maybe it was maybe it
wasn't but such a model and then it
applied that model it applied it with
great Nuance sometimes but it applied
that model and it doubled down on it and
at the point that model turns out to be
false they go down with the ship and
that happened in the space of a very
short time span with respect to covet
and often shouting about how they the
ship can't possibly be going down
because uh they were promised they were
assured they looked into it themselves
the model is right the model must be
right and that is the Curious thing
about this is if you check in with these
people
you do not get what I would ordinarily
expect of intellectuals which is at
least grudging acknowledgment that they
had taken a position that turned out not
to be right and maybe I would expect
amongst the lower quality ones excuse
making about how they got suckered by
some piece of evidence that mesmerized
them when they should have been looking
at something else but instead what you
find is a kind of insistence that no in
fact they were right and
they still are and so that is going to
be the red flag if your position on Cove
it hasn't changed radically then your
position isn't your position it's
something else right it's you deploying
a position held by something else and so
anyway what I'm going to argue yeah go
ahead there's
tummy
um
in science in the kinds of science that
we were trained in and and engaged in in
many rooms under many circumstances and
in many forests under many circumstances
uh we were assured that you don't prove
a hypothesis correct
that this was you know the
falsificationist uh kind of of science
sort of paparian thinking in which uh
you can
work very very hard uh to try to falsify
an idea a hypothesis and if you fail to
do that if you fail to falsify a
cherished or not cherished hypothesis
after a lot of hard work you have
greater and greater confidence that it
is true but you don't ever completely
know that it is true and so one of the
things that I hear you saying here is
um and we talked a couple weeks ago and
I wrote actually a couple weeks ago in
natural sections about the nature of
certainty that you know do do are you
comfortable with
an idea oh other people who I am
supposed to trust or I do trust say that
thing is correct therefore that's it one
hypothesis one thing that's it we're
done every decision I make is based
every the decision tree may go on there
may be Forks in the future but that is
unchanging
as opposed to
there's an there's a question there's an
observation there's a set of things
going on
what could explain them like a
hypothesis one which partially explains
this but doesn't explain that I got
hypothesis two which is counter to that
because it explains things differently
and they predict different things I've
got hypothesis three and you know
especially with something as complex as
covet the landscape of the last three
years it's you don't just have one set
of mutually exclusive hypotheses there's
the question of lab leak there's the
question of uh vaccine safety the
question of vaccine vaccine efficacy
of off-label treatments of all of the
various sorts that we that we have and
whether or not they're safe whether or
not effective as prophylaxis as
treatment so you know lots and lots of
different questions but for all of them
are you keeping multiple possibilities
alive in your mind at once or have you
concluded you know what this is it
nope I I will not ever ever
conclude that if it's called a vaccine
it could possibly be anything but safe
and effective
I think that's very well said and I
would uh
just add to it that one thing that is
true is
that corrupt science will inherently be
verificationist right that
falsificationism is incompatible it's
it's almost impossible to do it well
right you might pretend to be a
falsificationist but if you look under
the hood you will find verificationism
where where science has been corrupted
yeah
um but
let me just describe the two models and
you you will see I think why one of them
failed so badly with covet it always
fails but it failed so badly with covet
great the two models are you pick your
model of the universe or a particular
subset of the universe some discipline
how does X thing work and you apply it
as an expert but you don't question it
right and the other is you start
somewhere
and you start working towards a better
and better model by adjusting right now
my claim is going to be
I don't actually care where you start it
is better to start closer to the Target
but any process in which you actually
adjust with response to evidence will
eventually take you where you are going
and it will very rapidly surpass the
static application of anything but an
already excellent model someone
employing a self-correcting process who
is farther from the truth is someone you
would prefer to follow in their thinking
in their conclusions than someone who is
currently closer to the truth of that
matter but has is employing a static
model right now there is a degree of
difference in that if you have a very
mature understanding of some
set of facts then the model that
somebody adopts wholesale may be pretty
good to start with and so their failure
to adjust may not be a big handicap
right right but
what did we get with copen
we got a situation where nobody knew
anything right there were no good models
so the fact that X person's model was
three times as good as y person's model
had almost nothing to say about whether
it ended up better the question was are
you adjusting your model and improving
it or are you
keeping your model static and just
applying it and so what I'm going to
claim is that all of the people who
failed so spectacularly
have not substantially changed their
opinions now there will be little cases
pointed out where people made little
adjustments by and large the people who
uh say that the vaccines are safe and
effective have not changed their tune
they in fact started with that as an
assumption and they now report it as a
conclusion
and that this is actually evident
you know it just so happens that I
Tangled with both Claire and Sam over
this issue before there was coveted I
Tangled with them about the question of
whether or not vaccines are inherently
safe and my point is I I'm as I'm still
a big believer in this technology I
still think it's one of the most
marvelous success stories of traditional
vaccines and Technology vaccine
technology in principle however if
vaccines are safe it is because of a
system that prunes The Dangerous Ones
before they get to the public and we
know of multiple failures where vaccines
that were not safe got to the public and
we know of many other failures where
vaccines didn't get to the public but
failed in the testing phase and what
that tells you if vaccines are sometimes
not safe which we discover in testing
and sometimes not safe which we discover
after they've been released to the
public there's nothing inherently safe
about this technology right so if
vaccines are safe
it can only be because of an excellent
system that spots the ones that aren't
and keeps them away from you I know we
don't have an excellent system therefore
not safe right right not saying any
individual vaccine is harmful but I'm
saying the idea that they are inherently
safe is uh Dead on Arrival
and so if you adopted that especially if
you had it prior to covid and then
something was pointed at you and you
they said here is a vaccine safe and
effective and you of course it's safe
and effective they all are no that's
wrong you've already demonstrated that
applying your model is Gonna Leave You
in in the gutter right
and it also
you're you're still go no no go ahead uh
it it also betrays I think the
hesitation that we saw or early in covet
if you can remember
the spring of 2020.
and what we were seeing you know at that
point we were we were just beginning our
live streams and it was
yeah there was a lot of Terror there was
you know there was confusion all of this
but overwhelmingly one of my senses was
exhilaration with regard to the
scientific literature
because the scientific literature was uh
open there was so there were so many
people at that point who as far as I
know almost no one in the very early
days was being shut down yet very
quickly that started to happen but the
pre-print servers were just were just
full of papers and there was so much
going on there was so much research
being done that the voices of authority
that decide for you which ones are good
and which ones aren't weren't doing the
work right these hadn't even made it to
journals yet so the peer review process
which is ridiculously broken wasn't in
the way the editors weren't in the way
the journalists weren't in the way what
you had if you had the you know if if
if you had the wherewithal and the
interest as we did to actually wade into
the scientific literature as it was
being generated day by day in the spring
of 2020 it's like oh my God there's so
much here and yeah we can't possibly
assess all of it but how much preferable
it is
for us and it should be for for anyone
as time consuming as it is to go to the
source and say does this make sense is
this research good as opposed to well I
don't have time for that I'm going to
trust this guy who no one had ever heard
of before who happens to run an
organization that's under the NIH who
says no not that this that and oh in
fauci We Trust like that quickly became
the thing that people did because they
were scared they were confused they
didn't know they wanted someone
to look at and that guy had a conclusion
a few conclusions that we now can be
pretty sure almost all of them were not
helpful for Humanity and what we were
doing and what's so you know many people
were doing but mostly not people who
were on your screens were saying we
don't know we think this let's see let's
see what is being learned and that that
ability to actually look at the
scientific literature quickly got um got
polluted of course well it did get
polluted it got captured because frankly
people were paying attention to what we
and others were making of This emerging
literature and it got in the way of
whatever I still don't have any idea
what the actual plan of those who
enforced their narrative on us was but
the point is whatever that force was
that was enforcing its narrative
whatever its motivation was it very
quickly figured out that it couldn't
very well have us discussing
um the the you know pre-pere reviewed
literature with the public oh my
goodness right that's too dangerous but
I wanted to point out though
I was thinking about
the places that I personally have
adjusted my understanding in some cases
radically in some cases it has actually
flipped it's reversed
and it's a never-ending stream I spent a
couple minutes just thinking this
morning about places where I had uh
changed what I understood okay
and in fact I realized that
one of our first forays into this I made
a substantial error with respect to my
understanding of the science
the actual science which was I believed
that because we were dealing with an RNA
virus that it transcribed itself into
DNA it reverse transcribed itself and
installed itself in the genome which
turns out is not true for coronaviruses
so just to use one of the pieces of
jargon that many people would be
familiar with
um that you thought and you said on
stream as I remember it um that because
it was an RNA virus it was a retrovirus
yeah and not true not how they work so
okay embarrassing error for me right
away but immediately figured it out and
corrected it right exactly all right
I don't know how long I could go listing
all of the places where I changed my
understanding many of them maybe all of
them I think uh you share but
nonetheless I realized my position on
the functionality of hydroxychloroquine
completely inverted I believed which we
never talked about on air because it
just it just didn't even hit Radar
really this was actually my my biggest
embarrassment I do not have a good
explanation for how I missed the fact
that I was being misled by Propaganda on
this very useful drug until
embarrassingly late but anyway that one
was remarkably that one got us both in a
way that most of the you know things
like two weeks to flatten the curve like
a lot of things that a lot of people
accepted like we we never believed but
somehow the
it's a it's a trump delusion and it's
hydroxychloric when
and there was a flood of information in
all this but yeah I I bought that yep I
bought I bought it for a long time yeah
too long yeah and it's not true all
right uh Ivermectin effectiveness
um now mind you effectiveness on two
different fronts both as a treatment for
covid and as a prophylactic my position
on this has changed it has changed
slightly because one paper that appeared
to demonstrate extreme Effectiveness did
not turn out to be what it appeared to
be on first pass I still think the
experiment took place it gave a
compelling result but because the method
section
did not provide enough information and
the data set when I requested it was not
forthcoming is the one out of Argentina
yeah okay the this the carvio study the
experiment is not reproducible and so I
said
you have to take this piece of evidence
and give it zero evidentiary weight
because it is essential for science to
be repeatable
now I would make that criticism of many
experiments on the other side now too
but but didn't the Laurie uh the
meta-analysis remove it and get very
much the same results that was a
different study okay yeah so because it
was not a randomized controlled trial it
wasn't in there in the first place it's
a different study but yes and you know I
had tests on because I wanted people to
understand that the fact that you've got
a study that turns out to be fraudulent
does not invalidate a meta analysis that
included it in fact this is one of the
strengths of meta-analysis is that you
can simply say what happens if we
exclude this study what does it do to
the result and the answer was it didn't
change it very much but my position on
Ivermectin Effectiveness has largely
changed because I remectin Effectiveness
has largely changed because the virus
changed because the virus is is mutating
as viruses will do
especially with a strong selective Force
well strong selective Force now this one
perplexed me you know at first I thought
is it reduced in Effectiveness with
respect to the later variance because
um because resistance has evolved which
I initially said I didn't think was
going to happen yeah and
um apparently that is not what's going
on what's going on I feel like what
little I understand about Ivermectin
mechanism of action it wouldn't be
resistance resistance is unlikely
because there are multiple mechanisms of
action and so the point is progress
against one doesn't substantially alter
the fate of the virus in its context and
it's such a broad spectrum
anti-parasitic right right so what
apparently my understanding I think
largely from Garrett vandenbosch is that
what happened is the virus adopted a
different strategy in which It produced
many many more copies and so you had to
drive the effective dose of ivermectin
way up which then creates side effects
which are not terrible side effects but
nonetheless you don't want to be using
this as a prophylactic at a dose that
it's causing like visual side effects
and things like it's not like you don't
become a quadruped and start asking for
a saddle no that never happened that was
the FDA spreading misinformation
incidentally asterisk for later I know
we're on a roll here but um the fda's
lawyers made some interesting claims in
court recently about what they did and
did not say about Ivermectin yes
apparently we've got them telling us
that uh it was just a recommendation yes
just a recommendation but anyway okay so
my position on Iram active Effectiveness
has changed a little bit because my
understanding of the evidence changed
but also because I remarked an
Effectiveness changed and the point is a
model that is updating with evidence
then takes on the clinical change and
the effectiveness of this drug and
incorporates it the model that is static
that stuff doesn't work at all remains
static
um great well
the virus is evolving right like so so
even even a conclusion that is 100 right
at time a at time B may not be uh
precisely because the object in question
that you were talking about efficacy
against her for or whatever uh has
changed and therefore so should the
interaction with it right so so should
you expect the interaction with it too
so the point is a dynamic model is
inherently better for two different
reasons one it gets better with respect
to a static set of facts and two it's
the only game in town with respect to a
changing set of facts right and I don't
mean changing as in we know the facts to
be different but changing because
something is rapidly evolving for
example and therefore changing the
utility yeah
um
the next one on my list is mask
Effectiveness we were famously early or
I was particularly aggressive on the
potential utility of masks and them
especially the mask that I was
suggesting people use which was
practical because it wasn't such an
impediment to life turned out to be
essentially useless
cloth mask and 95 is better still not
effective but uh you know may have some
impact
vaccine Effectiveness I was quite
convinced by the initial propaganda it
now seems that came out of the trials
that were used to sell the vaccines to
us that the vaccines were likely to be
important in the control of the disease
we now know that they do not have even
the most basic characteristics that
would be necessary for them to be useful
in this regard but I was initially taken
in by the propaganda my position has
changed vaccine safety I was always
alarmed that these things couldn't
possibly be safe in the way they were
saying because safety doesn't mean
harmless safety means riskless and there
was an obvious long list of potential
risks that couldn't be eliminated at the
point these things emerged so I still
can't be still can't be but the point is
I was actually too cautious turns out
you know I was worried
that 20 years down the road we were
going to discover a longevity difference
between people who had taken these
things or some slow pattern of tumors or
autoimmunity would emerge wow did that
safety signal show up fast
um so anyway my position has moved in
the direction of wow these things not
only are they unsafe by virtue of being
risky but they appear to be doing a huge
amount of harm at the same time they're
not very effective at doing the one
thing that was of primary interest which
was controlling the spread of the virus
um
uh
coveted origin I initially had a chart
that uh go ahead uh I'm just I'm
reminded with that last one so um so far
you know I think we so far basically we
had the same same positioning on on
almost all of these things
um
the thing uh that was used to dismiss
those of us who were concerned about
code vaccine safety and efficacy early
on
was that we were inherently the same
people who minimized the risks of covet
itself
and uh actually so our friend Holly has
written a piece called
such a brilliant title the end of Faith
Harris in Sam Harris
and she actually she does she does right
by us and discusses
um you know his claim that we're those
people and says I I know they're not you
can just look at Dark Horse and see how
seriously they were taking covet but
also I Holly know they're not because I
had kova twice and here's how they
behaved towards me
so uh the thing
that I guess I want to add then to your
messaging here is
um the ways that people are dismissed
gets lumped into like you know oh if
you're a then you're a plus b it's like
but uh but I'm not and the fact that you
can't see that it's possible to be a not
b suggests again that you've been handed
a bill of goods that you've adopted a
model that you didn't think through that
you just accepted it right that the only
way
to be have concern about the safety of
the brand new to Human Experience
coveted vaccines was to also be a
coveted minimizer
is an absurd position and the fact is
actually that I think another place that
I at least
um
uh have have changed my positioning over
time in the almost three years is at
first we're like oh God you know what is
this no it's not the flu it's different
it seems to be worse not clear no it's
definitely not a cold
but the fact again is that not only do
we have more information now but we also
have a change in the disease itself now
long covet is is real and dangerous and
unfortunately at this point it's also
true that because both uh SARS Kobe 2
and the MRNA vaccines are using the
spike protein as the thing that uh well
SARS Kobe 2 isn't using the spike
protein but that is present in both of
them and it's because that is the source
of so much of the cytotoxicity uh it's
it's hard in many cases to tell the
difference between you know oh do you
have long covet are you vaccine injured
right it can it can it is at least
potentially hard to tell right it's a
confound it's it's potentially hard to
tell
but
it does seem that if you
don't
for whatever reason
your genetics your lack of comorbidities
your ability to treat early with all the
things that we know you can treat early
with have a mild case of covet and don't
have lingering effects
it doesn't have to be a big deal except
that we still don't know what the
long-term effects very long-term effects
might be yep
um I would say that there's a big
lurking question to the extent that
people are trying to apply uh what we're
talking about you know okay how am I not
going to be on the wrong side of this
how am I going to build an active model
that gets better over time especially if
you're not somebody trained in a
relevant field well part of the trick is
figuring out how to proxy
trust and revoke it if somebody doesn't
do this job very well yeah but I would
say one question that remains very
active in my mind
is what are the chances that if we
hadn't deployed the vaccines we'd be
done
but this would legitimately have burned
itself out and while that will sound
fanciful can you be you're saying it
would not have become endemic I am
saying that because let me point
something out Wuhan one it's gone it's
extinct and so the question is did herd
immunity Drive Wuhan 1 to Extinction
I've never heard that term before I can
extrapolate what you mean move on one
you're you're busy with a it's not wild
type but like you know if if sarskovy II
hadn't been Frank engineered in a in a
lab it would be the wild type the
original virus that uh that we were all
dealing with in spring 2020. right so
that thing is and you know I will say
that there is a complex set of questions
around viral swarms which I think are
not well dealt with and need to be
understood but one very live possibility
according to my model and who knows next
week I may understand why my model is
wrong and therefore this line of inquiry
doesn't make sense but one very live
possibility
is that if we had done nothing that
drove the evolution of these uh these
viruses that we would be done by virtue
of herd immunity which would have been
painfully acquired with many many deaths
but nonetheless we'd be finished and
that the they're finished with the virus
not finished as Humanity right finished
with the virus covid would have burned
itself out right
um we'll never know I don't know that
we'll never know I think we will never
know for sure
I think the point is this is a tractable
question this is a studyable question
and what we have done by deploying a
cartoonishly narrow vaccine is we have
Amplified The evolutionary signal we
have asked the we have asked Evolution
to play a game that it is master of
right not only can you adapt but can you
adapt to something stupidly narrow of
course you can right easily and again
and again so
um
so in any case this is a place where and
I'm going to argue that the the right
way to think about these complex
problems is to get over your instinct to
LEAP to a conclusion to LEAP to a
conclusion of any kind really right the
point is you should maintain these
things probabilistically
and yeah tough for people right so tough
for people but because people want
certainty
this I know well so that that is true it
is true that's what people want but you
know I used to I used to play this game
with our kids where if they said
something with certainty I used to say
what do you think the probability is
that that's not true and of course how
certain are you for very young children
the answer 100 of course and the answer
is no you just screwed up you just told
me something wrong yeah the probability
should not be zero it might be a tiny
fraction of one percent
right the tiny fraction but and you know
I mean let's um very young children you
expect that answer and you know of
course but the point is you got to break
that habit right you got to break that
habit and what we have and you did that
is an adult expert class that we are now
detecting never got that lesson right
they and so what this does is it creates
a very bad mechanism for thinking that
is cryptic in any place where your
intellectual ancestors have done a
decent job right so the point is if you
walk into physics right and you adopt
the standard model the standard model is
pretty good it's pretty predictive and
you can become expert at it but you're
not going to extend it if what you're
doing is taking on that model and using
it as a set of assumptions which is fair
but if that's all you do then the point
is you can't detect where this thing
doesn't work right right you're just
going to keep applying it and you're
going to you're going to rationalize it
if you really don't know anything about
the philosophy of science
or the history of science preferably
mostly the philosophy if you have to
choose one it's the philosophy of
science
you probably can't do science well
because you don't don't have the model
for what it looks like when there is
uncertainty
um I agree with that and I also think
it's a it's a little a little tough to
say
for sure but one thing that is true you
mentioned Holly's excellent essay on Sam
and one of the things that she says in
that essay is that Sam was an
intellectual hero to her and that twice
Sam had delivered something into the
world that had revolutionized her world
for the better right one of these things
was the questioning of faith and the
other was his treatment of lying
and her point was now she is forced to
part ways with her intellectual hero
because her intellectual hero is doing
things that not only are unacceptable
but don't fit with his own stated
beliefs on these things before without
acknowledging that he's changed but
here's the funny thing about that he's
not the only close friend of ours who
said this
this is a common phenomenon
and
um wait he's not the only close friend
of ours who said but she oh okay Holly
is not the only close friend of ours if
I said he that was uh because the other
friend I'm thinking of is he but I I
think this is a relatively
uh common position where people who got
something from Sam because he was good
at this in some regard
are now in stuck in the position of
having to try to a grapple with what was
the stuff that I believed
that was important before if he's now
speaking in direct violation of it he's
effectively okay with a conspiracy
against Trump you know in the 2020
election yeah
um then he's obviously not against lying
so what was this whole treatment of
lying yeah right so what was that but
um anyway what I'm going to argue is if
you are one of these people who
whether you always did or something
about recent history has caused you to
embrace a I'm going to find the best
model and I'm gonna stick with it no
matter what right if you do that then a
couple things are true
one
u a we can spot that you're doing it
because if you think about how such a
person
would change their mind right you would
have basically a threshold question have
you reached the point where the thing
that you thought was uh
less than 50 percent likely is now more
than 50 percent likely at which point
you would have to acknowledge a change
until then there's no Nuance as long as
you think it's less likely to be true
than the competitor we don't see your
changing understanding of anything right
the only thing you're reporting is a
binary is a binary exactly then the
point is two things one there's this
totally arbitrary Threshold at 50
percent where your opinion appears to
suddenly snap into the other
confirmation that's not how thinking
works right two you're much more easily
gamed right because the thing is how do
you keep somebody who is using this
cruddy mechanism for thinking on your
team all you got to do is feed them
enough garbage to keep them from hitting
the threshold it doesn't have to be
perfect they can have their own private
doubts but the point is you just feed
them enough [ __ ] that they don't hit
50 and flip yeah right and so I think
we're seeing a lot of that I mean for
one thing we know that Sam
proxied part of his understanding to
Eric topel right Aaron topple is
um Kristen Anderson's boss so he has a
perverse incentive that goes back to lab
leak right this isn't somebody you
should proxy to likewise Anthony fauci
right Anthony fauci is uh the person who
offshored the work to Wuhan to get
around the ban on gain of function
research right but why does he show up
here you're talking about him proxying
his or him being a proxy for someone
being a proxy but for a lot of people
yeah so you have covid descends nobody
knows anything about it what are you
going to do well I'm going to listen to
the people who know the most about it
well who is that one of them is Anthony
fauci oh good choice you know why
because he stood there with his head in
his hands while Trump was saying crazy
things right so Anthony fauci becomes
super reliable because he's the opposite
of trump and of course that's a
brilliant way to get Sam's attention
right so the point is okay I'm going to
proxy to that guy because he feels the
same about Trump as I do right okay well
then Anthony fauci now has a direct line
into whoever is listening to Sam right
so much better
if we were able to tune into the oh boy
I said these things were safe but now
I've seen a few things I still think
they're probably safe but wow I don't
I'm not as convinced of that as I was
because I've seen a few things that
caused me to wonder right that's the
natural process right
um but no but no public Revelation
instead instead we get some some garbage
excuse like well I'm not going to get
boosted because the CDC lies
and
right but that's that's a non-sec where
it doesn't make any sense it's not an
argument right it's what it is is
evidence of not thinking and my
overarching point is
we saw our entire expert class reveal
that they were not thinking that they
were doing something else at least in
this case and I would argue that
probably that's because it's the habit
of thinking that they got into and if
what you did was uh looked at the com
the competitors to this
and said who are these people and what
exactly do they think they know and the
answer is it doesn't really matter if
they're using the equivalent of
selection to build a model that works
from any starting place they will
quickly outpace a group that has proxied
in the early days of a chaotic situation
where nobody knows anything so the best
model they could possibly have embraced
was bad yep right and the idea that
anybody is sticking with their initial
impression of vaccines of repurposed
drugs of covet origins of any of these
things of the evolution of variants of
any of them nobody could possibly be
making Headway with their initial model
because it just simply wasn't enough to
go on to build a decent model so the
only people the only game in town is
people who's thinking evolves by a
process that really is very parallel to
Natural Selection right I mean that's
really the core point is what do you
trust to build your model right do you
trust
picking the right one you know well that
can work great if a bunch of really
refined models exist and you know none
of them are full of corrupt garbage yeah
but any other situation no I want
something that irrespective of what
model I've ended up in can morph into a
model that works that's what I want and
um and the problem is I think
the uh the propaganda engine was very
good at portraying the process of
evolution as evidence that it was not
valid in other words well if this thing
makes errors
right
ah well and and you know and that's
that's classic media response right who
was it who was it who in part lost the
presidential election because he was
accused of being a flip-flopper is that
John Kerry that would be I think that
was John Kerry yeah so
whenever that was
um you know the idea that you've changed
your mind as a politician that that's
going to be the thing that means you
can't hold office like I'm not saying
that John Kerry would or would not have
been an excellent president but the idea
that having changed your mind and being
on record saying one thing and then
later saying a different thing well
that's just too far like that that tells
us like if people can be fooled by that
then we then people can be fooled by
anything yep if if if if they really
believe the change in your opinion
as a politician is should mean that you
should not be in high office well then
we're done we're doomed frankly right
right it is a poison pill for anything
that would function the right way yeah
um so I wanted to uh close out this
section with a couple of observations
one I wanted to
um point out there's something that I
you've heard me say many times I think
I've said it quite a number of times on
Dark Horse that
um if you say something that is wrong
right if you get something wrong the
process of admitting that you got it
wrong
is very painful for all of us
but some of us are good at it why are we
good at it because the pain that you
experience in publicly having to reverse
yourself is such a tiny fraction of the
burden that comes to you if you refuse
to correct it that it's a bargain
expensive as it is it's a bargain right
now if you do it all the time people
will correctly infer that you're not
doing thinking very well because you're
constantly having to correct yourself
but if you do your work well so that you
don't have to correct yourself that
often and then you do correct yourself
when you need to that actually increases
people's trust in you because they know
why you're trustworthy which is that
you'll fix it if you got it wrong and
you'll alert them right so here's the
crazy thing about that
I don't know how many times I've said
that but I've given that riff many many
times in many contexts I also believe
Sam has given that risk that riff almost
exactly right he has described this
process which means that at the very
least his conscious mind is aware of
this relationship
now
I think he's caught in a bind I think
Sam has two ideological commitments in
Conflict he's a little bit like how in
2001 that has two conflicting programs
um you remember that
yes yeah I just think that maybe the
first time that that those two
characters have been
um possibly compared to one another but
I think Sam has a belief in institutions
which I understand because frankly we're
really screwed if they don't work but
punchline they don't work I'm not a one
they're all busted and we're more
screwed if they don't work and most of
us are pretending that they do right
that's that's the worst of Both Worlds
so I think Sam has a desire to recognize
what's wrong with the institutions fix
them and get back to work and I think
the point is it's way later than you
think Sam those institutions are way
more corrupted than you understand
they're not coming back right and you
don't want any part of them because they
will do to you what they just did to you
with covid right they will mislead you
and they will turn you into a fool right
that's not what you want to do so at the
same time that he has a commitment to
the idea that institutions are the way
that we prevent Oblivion which I think
is not wrong right that we need
institutions that work to prevent us
from arranging Oblivion for ourselves
he's also committed to the idea that
when you get stuff wrong you should
correct it
and that these two things are in
competition and that his move this week
to leave is about one of these things
having one out over the other and it's
the exact wrong one these institutions
don't work they won't be rebooted and
trying you know rationalizing that
they're still close enough to functional
that you can invest more in them and
maybe you know put them right is not a
viable thing and I think frankly the
alternative that the institutions are so
far gone that you should do a proper
accounting correct your model and
apologize for what you got wrong explain
how it happened and rejoin the
conversation is the right thing to do
and Sam has headed 180 degrees away from
it yeah he chose the wrong alternative
at this moment instead of absenting
himself from this conversation he should
pay the price of getting back into
reality space
and he should move forward and he should
contribute to the conversation as he did
and you know affecting people the way he
has affected good friends of ours
um by altering their understanding of
the world that would be the right thing
to do and I you know I hope that some
time contemplating this off of Twitter
causes him to realize that and you know
again I hope people if he does do the
right thing here people will be generous
to him and they will you know
not fail to notice how wrong he got
things but understand how it is that
that happened
um I think that would be
really important
now the last thing I wanted to do here
is connect this
to what we are seeing with Elon Musk
because I think if we take the model
that you and I just talked about where
there are two kinds of thinking is one
kind of thinking that takes a model and
applies it and becomes expert in how to
apply it but doesn't change it doesn't
question it and there's another model
where you use Evolution to get to reason
I think it explains some of what we're
seeing with musk in a way that it is at
least worth contemplating
um so it goes kind of like this
musk buys Twitter there's some very
interesting uh I won't say Cloak and
Dagger stuff exactly but some
four-dimensional chess in the purchasing
of Twitter on again off again you know
he buys it it was a surprise right and
then he uh carries the sink in the front
door and things go crazy suddenly people
are you know it's hemorrhaging employees
except wait a second is it really
hemorrhaging if those employees weren't
doing anything right oh Twitter's gonna
or they're doing the opposite of what
they should have been doing right
exactly so okay how much is musk not in
control of his ship versus how much does
musk understand exactly what this is and
he's getting rid of these people because
he knows that he can't fix Twitter if
they're still at their desks or at least
able to log in or whatever it is that
they were doing right so anyway when
let me acknowledge something about my
model
I don't know that musk Is For Real
I am behaving like musk is for real
because if he isn't
I don't know what the alternative play
is we are in a very dire situation
without any institutions that function
without any places where we can discuss
what's true
there isn't a good plan for how to fix
the direction we're headed we're in very
serious trouble so I want musk to be for
real because I think it's very important
that Twitter become the first place that
we can have a rational discussion and
who knows how long
I am not going to delude myself into
believing that he's for real because it
would be great and really important if
he was in other words I maintain this as
it's not motivated reasoning because
it's not affecting my estimation of How
likely he is to be for real I am just
maintaining this as this is worth it's
it's a little bit like the puzzle
if you are in a canoe and you are headed
towards a waterfall that will kill you
when you go over it do you paddle
towards Shore yes do you paddle towards
Shore if there is a 98 chance that your
paddling will be futile yes do you
continue to paddle towards Shore if
there is a
99.9999 chance that it will be futile
yes in fact until you know for sure that
there's nothing you could do you paddle
because what else have you got so
unless you're looking for death you
fight for your life until you can't
fight anymore right you do it and that's
frankly Evolution has built this to do
that right you do it so I'm hoping that
he's for real I believe I see evidence
that he's for real but I believe that
evidence is confusing people and it's
confusing people for exactly the reason
that they were confused by US during
covet all right so if you look at when I
say on Twitter something like zero is a
special number this is a very important
battle that's going on really we should
be backing his play all of these things
I get responses that are like you don't
understand
he's just like the rest of them right
he's as enmeshed in the machine as
anybody blah blah blah blah blah and
they come up with examples right you
know Ukraine right Ukraine is obviously
not the story that we understood it's
not just simply a tyrant having attacked
innocent people and the president isn't
a you know gloriously handsome
courageous freedom fighter and all the
[ __ ] that we were sold the you know
the the Ukrainian pilot who was knocking
Russians out of the sky you know left
and right all of this was just some it
was Wag the Dog right it doesn't tell us
what the real story is but there's some
real story and that ain't it
right well musk provided starlink to
Ukraine for military purposes
so is that an invalidation of the idea
that musk is on the right side because
he's invested in this garbagey war
whatever its meaning is as anybody else
likewise you know there's some
famous tweet about vaccines where he
goes all in on the idea that we should
be vaccinating people for covet as a
mechanism
for controlling it right so anyway
they're all of these cases
where he or you know his belief in uh
um neuralink and you know basically
linking brains to computers is this a
good idea or is this the end of the
world
here's my point
I think the most parsimonious
explanation for this human being's
behavior is that he is
a very smart very independent thinker
who is using and evolving mode
in order to get to better and better
models
and that um
boy I just lost the key piece of this uh
oh the bias towards action so there's
this phrase in startup World bias
towards action and the idea is yes you
could
spend more and more time trying to think
of better and better ways to make your
thing launch right or at some point you
could say it is time to take the
imprecise thing we've got and launch it
and then move forward you know use the
momentum to get somewhere and obviously
you don't want no thinking in advance of
action but a bias towards action means
that this person is actually biased in
the direction of executing
so musk clearly has an incredible bias
towards action the number of projects
that he has uh you know brought to
viability is incredible and the nature
of those products is impressive I mean
you know okay you're gonna go after the
Auto industry and you're gonna convert
some large fraction of you know the
moving back and forth to electric and
there are no gas stations so how are you
gonna
how does anybody drive anywhere without
gas stations well we'll do that part
right so he's a bias towards action guy
who has an evolving model and all of the
places where people say nah he's just
like the others are cases where he's
said something that he thought was right
based on what he had and his model has
moved on and maybe he hasn't updated
exactly but nonetheless I think the
point is maybe he actually is for real
and maybe this play is what it looks
like and maybe you know he's now
updating his model from the inside of it
he's willing to be wrong and more than
willing to update right
and boy do I hope that's right because
why are we in trouble if it's not yeah I
I hope that's right too
um I actually have one more piece that's
going to seem like a total non-sequitur
to add to the two type of people in the
world argument that you've made here
which analogizes it to how people play
Wordle
do you know Wordle barely okay so
um for the uninitiated of which I
figured you might sort of be uh and
which I can therefore assume some people
in the audience are it's a single player
word game create a few years back by
this Welsh engineer named Wardle
um and for his girlfriend I think um
although it Bears similarity to some
older games
pre-internet games and then New York
Times bought it this year and so it's
really it's mostly you can get it not
behind a paywall but the New York Times
now limits you can play like one a day
basically you have six tries to gas a
five letter word and for each of your
guesses all of which have to be
legitimate English words
in each of the five letter positions you
are told whether that letter doesn't
exist in the word at all gray box uh
exists in the word but not in the
position you put it in a yellow box or
not only does that letter exist in the
word the answer word but you got it in
the right position a green box
and uh here Zach I'm going to ask you to
show my screen so this is just from the
Wikipedia entry on Wordle this is an
example of a game in which someone's
first guess was arise the answer was
Rebus they got it in six tries but you
can see here so usually when people
report out their answers you see people
reporting out without the letters in the
words their answers which is just a
combination of gray yellow and green
squares which is the first time which is
the first way that I ran into Wordle is
people were putting out these just they
look like hieroglyphs like I couldn't
tell what it was but you can see in this
game that that someone played and then
put on Wikipedia uh the second
word
guest has an initial letter of R and
each subsequent guess
also has an initial letter of r
the person here used the strategy of I
know that's an R I'm never going to
guess anything but R because R is r r is
there so this is an example of a game
that I found online I just went through
Twitter for people looking at uh
looking for people who haven't posted
their answers this is a standard sort of
thing that you'll see on Twitter this is
how I think most people are playing
Wordle as soon as you get a green square
again the second line there the second
line the second position as soon as you
get a green square you stick you never
try anything else
this is not the best way to end up
figuring out what your word is going to
be so I went and just played one game
and it looks a little bit different and
unfortunately I got too lucky the first
time so this is this is actually
the better approach that is more likely
to end with you at truth ultimately but
may have you living in deep uncertainty
with nothing right in the interim so my
first guess here I happened to guess
something where four of my letters are
correct but only one of them is in the
right position
for my second guess even though I only
was missing one letter and maybe this
wasn't even exactly the right move here
but because I only had the one New York
Times anyway I only had the one thing I
picked another word with five common
letters none of which I had already used
to see if any of them were in the
correct answer right and they weren't
and that allowed me actually to go like
okay what's left what's left and so you
know this is not a perfect example
because it makes it look too clean and
that's not usually how it's going to be
you're going to have a lot more
uncertainty early on but um hold on one
more Zach
um just put my screen back on for a
second and then this is so by contrast
this one is a perfect example of why
this doesn't work this is just another
one I ran into today on Twitter like
okay this person guessed their first
guess
two of the letters are right one of
them's in the right position their
second guess four of the letters are in
the right position
they didn't get it they didn't win they
didn't solve the they didn't solve the
Wordle because instead like an unlike
covid where there's a lot of complexity
and it changes over time in Wordle like
oh you know in that case the first
second fourth and fifth positions you
always will know that and no amount of
other guessing is going to take that
away from you
for God's sake people don't stick with
those four letters you're learning
nothing you're learning Nothing by
continuing to put those same letters
into those same positions over and over
and over again
find words that have as little in common
with the information you already have
and try those out see how those things
that's really interesting so what you're
effectively describing is a mental
algorithm that keeps you stuck on a low
Peak yes yeah yeah exactly wow and that
is highly relevant to what we've been
talking about and it also is relevant
one of the things that I think is a
problem for Sam is that Sam in his own
mind imagines that he's perfectly
consistent right Sam is a bundle of
contradictions right a guy who believes
that there is exactly zero free will but
that it is very important that we be
vigilant about moral issues is in
conflict with himself now there's
nothing wrong with that if you say I
believe these two things I know them to
be mutually exclusive I believe they
both have some truth and I don't know
how they reconcile I'm interested I
don't know but I'm not giving up either
one of these things because I don't
think either one of them is so wrong
that it needs to be thrown out right
that's something you can hear right you
know or Jordan Peterson right Jordan
Peterson does this well right do you
believe you know in uh you know a God
who answers prayers
I act as if I do right right the point
is that's how you do this you
don't claim that my belief system is
consistent across the board you say
here's a Zone where I'm relatively
confident here's a Zone where I'm
relatively confident the thing in
between is a place I can't be confident
because I can see as well as anyone else
that doesn't fit right and so that that
ability to get from a low Peak to a
higher Peak
is I believe tantamount to how much of
your own uncertainty you can tolerate
exactly right yes like you need to be
able to live in the uncertainty and you
know Frank part part of why for instance
people who have actually traveled
including you know immigrants who've
actually lived in two very different
countries but people who have traveled
and not just gone to the Disney version
of you know your home uh in whatever
place it is but actually traveled
what you're doing is going into
uncertainty and saying I'm gonna have to
be okay with this and frankly people who
travel a lot are
indicating something about their
personality which says I'm more than
okay with this I I kind of love the
uncertainty I love the Serendipity I
love the opportunity to learn things
that I did not see coming yep and I will
uh if I can Pat myself on the back I
think one of my better skills one of the
reasons that I do well in this game is
that I have a Prater natural capacity to
file questions as open and leave them
there literally for decades sometimes
and the experience is you even forget
that you've got a question active it's
simmering so low on a back burner that
you don't even really think of it
but it isn't closed you haven't left to
a conclusion just to close it out
and then years later sometimes decades
later the thing that you didn't know
emerges and just the Cascade of like oh
that completes and then it has all of
these effects and the other things that
you weren't able to put together it's a
marvelous it's a marvelous experience
yeah and I think it really is a question
of
um we have a bad habit our bad habit is
leaping to conclusions and that happens
at every scale and basically to the
extent that you have that tendency
um it's it's an Achilles heel
and I would also say that the flip side
of this the way you know we alluded to
this earlier but the way not to fall
into this trap is very socially
dangerous but
straightforward which is to file things
as possibilities right so if we talk
about for example
conspiracy theories
you should be able to take every
conspiracy theory
and you should be able to say well what
I may believe let's take let's take a
good one right the moon landing was fake
I don't believe the moon landing was
fake I believe we landed on the moon I
believe it was a profoundly important
historical event but I don't rate the
chances that it was fake at zero right
in fact I've delved into that conspiracy
theory and I've noticed there are
actually some pieces of evidence in it I
don't know how to answer right things
that are important
so I have a very low probability that
actually what I was handed in terms of
the moon landing is obscuring another
truth right but just as when you would
ask our our boys when they were younger
they mostly don't need to be asked this
anymore right right at 18 and 16. uh you
know how certain are you of that
an answer of a hundred percent or of
zero percent is basically a non-starter
yep right so
there are things that you you know do I
have needs yeah I'm 100 sure of that
um but there is very little that goes
into any kind of complexity space that
you should rank as a zero percent or a
hundred percent well I gotta say the
knees you're gonna go after the knees
going after that I know as soon as I
said it
well the reason to do it yeah of course
as soon as you said it you can spot and
I'm sure given a minute and a half you
will find your own you know reason to
reserve a very tiny percentage chance
that you don't have knees but uh well
all right here but he you you haven't
heard this from me yet I've been holding
it back and I'm not going to fully
explore it here but I will give you the
tantalizing tin bit
um
I have been mocking people including
Elon Musk for his claim that there's a
good chance we're living in a simulation
okay
um for one thing his logic here which is
common to other people is garbage right
the logic is well the number of
simulations has to outnumber the number
of real universes by a huge amount
therefore statistically speaking this is
probably one right which is such a bad
argument right it's really really bad
because hey we don't know that there are
any simulations of any level of depth
that have ever existed so there may be
one universe and no simulations which
means that all the universes are real so
anyway whatever you can you can take
that apart however I had the very
uncomfortable experience
a couple weeks ago
of realizing that although I still think
the chances that we are living in a
simulation are really really tiny that
the chances that we are living in a
simulation took a giant leap forward in
my own understanding even though I
really don't like the idea and will be
so disappointed border I feel like giant
leap forward is like Final Solution I'm
just one of these phrases
he even mounted and say giant leap
forward did he
um no so anyway it's something you know
the chances that we were living in a
simulation to me was like one in
ten thousand okay um maybe put in a
hundred thousand yeah what happened
uh I realized that some
relatively commonly accepted uh
observations
are consistent with this in a way so
that I still think it's less than one
percent chance but it took a giant leap
in the right direction I will come back
to this I told you I'm not going to
provide the evidence yet I want to run
it by a couple of people and just make
sure that I'm not you know I haven't
lost my mind
um
okay
I guess at the moment you sound like you
have right exactly exactly but okay
final final thing from my perspective I
promised uh we got some more stuff to
talk about but all right well then we
can uh we can reserve this final final
thing well it is kind of late uh I guess
I wanted to
I wanted to finish on pairs if I may a
brief thing on pairs but first I already
alluded to the um
FDA claim that the FDA is telling people
not to take Ivermectin was just a
recommendation I just wanted to very
quickly and I'll link to The Epic Times
article on this in the show notes
a reminder of some of the things that
are true many of which we talked about
here on Dark Horse the FDA created a web
page in 2021 titled why you should not
use Ivermectin to treat or prevent
covid-19 and later posted a link to the
page on Twitter with a text you are not
a horse you are not a cow seriously
y'all stop it
was the y'all that really made that
y'all yeah a second Twitter post from
the FDA was hold your horses y'all
Ivermectin may be trending but it still
isn't authorized or approved to treat
coven 19.
in a separate page the FDA stated Q
should I take every mechan to prevent or
treat covid-19 a
okay so that and we have heard from many
doctors uh and um have experienced
that doctors were you know shunned and
scared into not writing every Mission
prescriptions at all and those who did
were being told uh by pharmacists by
their patients that the pharmacist would
not fill them so uh this was it and that
was because the FDA had this you know
shame and fear campaign going on uh but
from one of the government's lawyers
quoted
quote sorry the cited statements were
not directives they were not mandatory
they were recommendations they said what
parties should do they said for example
why you should not take Ivermectin to
treat coven 19. they did not say you may
not do it you must not do it they did
not say it's prohibited or it's unlawful
they also did not say that doctors may
not prescribe Ivermectin
that's it all right this suggests a
marvelous new government uh instigated
game called Simon didn't say yeah
yeah yeah yeah
um actually and Malone has predicted
that we would soon be hearing a great
chorus of well we didn't force you to
take the vaccines
um which I believe is coming as well
yeah and you know I was I bring I ran
into even more sort of Hollywood and uh
entertainment royalty this week who you
know last year mostly not not recently
but got on the vaccine bandwagon and
either strongly urged people or said yes
to mandates people like George Clooney
and Dolly Parton who are you know widely
beloved uh who I know uh well I will say
Hollywood
is the most intense
intellectual Echo chamber on the planet
by far the degree to which the you know
no defections are tolerated and these
people are guilty of this well our model
was what fauci says goes and we're not
budging the degree you know I saw I I
guess it was a recent interview in which
George Clooney was questioned about now
that's I I think somehow that's doing
the rounds game with us from 2021 oh it
is okay well then I uh hopefully George
Clooney who I like and respect is smart
enough to have seen through this by now
if not George look back into it
um but actually this does bring me to
the uh the final that I wanted to get to
which has to do with what to do with the
died suddenly film that emerged uh last
week I think this this week sometime
yeah um you've seen it I did I did watch
it so it was it was a Twitter Premiere
somehow right I think they premiered it
on Twitter
uh it's like I don't think it was a
Twitter Premiere I think it was
announced on Twitter and it was a rumble
Premiere but that doesn't really matter
it premiered somewhere this week you and
I have both seen it I will tell you I
accidentally I was watching on my phone
and there was I was trying to get out of
a mode in which you saw all of the
comments scrolling through and I hit a
button that I did not realize was
retweet and the next comment I saw was
Brett Weinstein has retweeted this so I
immediately deleted that tweet but
anybody who saw it because they have an
alert targeted at me or because of the
vagaries of Twitter don't take that as
any indication of anything was
non-intentional and you can tell that
because I deleted it within seconds
um but
I did want to give some guidance on how
to think about this thing I had a
conclusion you and I have not talked
about what your conclusion might be so
just I mean for those
it's called died suddenly and it's it's
about
uh the effects that the filmmakers
um purport to see from a variety of
sources uh of the widespread adoption of
the covet vaccines right now I'm alarmed
about this documentary uh I would say at
two levels of alarm
one I believe it contains something
potentially very very important
and it has fused that something to
things that make it suspect yeah
the thing that I think is very important
and I'm not saying that this is true but
I'm saying it would be so easy to
falsify if it wasn't true that if we
can't falsify it that's going to tell us
something that is a kind of piece of
information the thing that it brings to
light that one needs to take seriously
is the possibility
that morticians are seeing in cadavers a
novel kind of what is being described as
a clot but it's not really a clot white
fibrous white fibrous extremely large
artery and vein blocking both masses you
might call them plaques but in any case
the idea the basics that have internal
coherence and so can be pulled out about
cadaver right and they apparently have
not just the veins but the arteries
which is yeah the consistency of rubber
bands or calamari is how they're being
described now I saw the first place I
encountered this was Stephen Crowder
interviewed one of the same morticians
who was talking about his observation
and alarm and his talk with other
morticians and what I would say is
this film made by a guy named Stu
s-t-e-w Peterson
um he's at least one of The Producers
right who I don't follow I don't even
really recognize him except that there
was an earlier thing where he was
involved in advancing a story about
snake venom and uh the vaccines that
turned out to be nonsense
um a story that we also didn't uh back
or believe in
in any case
the mortician reports these
calamari-like clots there's lots of
footage of them not only preserved in
vials but in this film there's footage
of them being pulled from cadavers could
that be faked of course it could be
faked on the other hand it has it raises
a relatively obvious question
are there morticians who are not seeing
this who will come forward and saying
yeah not seeing it in my Mortuary
right there ought to be lots of those if
this is fake and what I will tell you is
the people that I don't know well but
that I'm in conversation with have
friends in the the so-called death carry
industry who validate the story that
these things exist so if these things
exist and the timing of them
is what it appears to be which is to say
not consistent with it being a coveted
phenomenon yes consistent with it being
a post-vaccine phenomenon then it needs
to be investigated it is utterly
unambiguous that this is an important
question and the problem is that this
film
overtly almost fuses it to utter
nonsense right it fuses it there's like
a montage in the beginning with Bigfoot
and 911 stuff and I can't remember what
else but it was like a smorgasbord I
don't know how you pronounce that
Smorgasbord I think only if you're the
the chef and the Muppets it that way I'm
not but in any case it fuses it to these
other things and
um so I read that as there's lots of
kooky ideas out there and some of them
turn out to be true right with them not
I just I read that opening montage
generously Perhaps Perhaps too
generously as we the makers of this film
may or may not believe in the you know
conspiracy theories that you will
associate with footage of 9 11 of
Sasquatch of the moon landing of this
that the other but uh you know the
Kennedy assassination and let me just
you know add that one in there because
you know Kennedy assassination which is
one that
I think a large proportion of Americans
are like yeah that was especially
Americans with brains
um yeah so yeah I would say actually let
me just add one in there where like I'm
comfortable saying yeah that is not what
the Warren Commission said it was right
right
my point would be unfortunately I think
your mind is playing a trick on you
where it is rationalizing away an
unforgivable
um connection right if this calamari
clock thing is for Real
then it needs to exist on its own so
that we can figure out what it implies
about the rest of our models of this
thing that we didn't know yet to in any
way bring it close to anything
Preposterous like Bigfoot which I would
rate the likelihood of Bigfoot being
real in the Pacific Northwest
as extremely unlikely just in light of
the fact that we never find skulls or
skeletons or get a good picture or
whatever and we know that people have
hoaxed you know and so I mean you're now
you're now in it because you're now
going to get the Bigfoot Community
coming after us but luckily it doesn't
include in the actual Bigfoot so yeah
exactly I'd be more concerned but anyway
point being unforgivable to fuse those
things also unforgivable to take
incredibly important sources like
um like Peter McCullough radical like
Ryan Cole
um Steve Kirsch to have these people in
a film in which low quality stuff
garbage stuff and this very important
observation yeah so there's there's a
few errors right like we haven't uh the
that's I don't even remember what it is
that they're showing but they're talking
about some very unlikely events that
have actually happened yeah and three
times in a row like the probability is a
zero and I was actually yelling at my
computer like duh don't do that right
like no the probability cannot be zero
of the thing that happened right they
right they basically are making an
argument a correct argument about the
number of standard deviations out we are
and therefore how unlikely this is and
then they are they're basically rounding
to zero right right and it's yeah you
don't round to zero in fact it's exactly
the subject of this episode of Dark
Horse that we've been talking about the
point is you can have a very very low
probability and it's not the same thing
as zero
um
but
anyway so what I'm gonna I still think I
have knees though
not if this is a simulation you don't
I mean I think the simulation of me and
the simulation thinks I have needs oh
yeah there's too many simulations but
then that would happen let's agree that
you either have knees or simulated knees
but
um similarly no it's really three it's
knees simulated knees or imaginary knees
I mean you could be a schizophrenic
quadriplegic who thinks they have knees
my quadriplegic still at knees they just
don't work oh uh amputee double amputee
yeah thanks
sorry I'm just trying to be complete
about the various hypotheses here
believe me the one I believe in is the
one that you have knees
yes yes but anyway my advice to our
audience was going to be actually as
much as I would like to tell you don't
watch this film because we don't know
what it is
the clot stuff the pseudo clock whatever
these structures are rubber band
calamari whatever it is watch it
evaluate for yourself what are the
chances that these morticians it's not
an infinite number of morticians in this
uh piece what are the chances that they
are not what they appear that they're a
plant you know placed to convince us
that these structures are real and that
it will turn out not to be true because
every other mortician in the western
world is going to stand up and tell us
hey wait a second I haven't seen one of
these things right what are the chances
and don't those chances drop every day
that the morticians don't rise up and
denounce this film saying hey those
things aren't real right so
anyway I would say watch the film
um do not let the film color your view
of Ryan Cole of Steve Kirsch uh of Peter
McCullough
process these things independently and
the film could be
malicious nonsense designed to take this
very important and effectively
uncontrovertible and controvertible
piece of evidence and get rid of it by
by muddling it it could be that process
it separately process the observations
the interviews go back and look at
Stephen Crowder's interview and then
watch what develops in the coming weeks
is this being used to get rid of that
evidence by saying oh it's part of some
giant conspiracy theory that involves
Bigfoot and 911 and who knows don't do
that right process the information that
these morticians seem to be giving you
independently
and leave the rest of the film out
because it's not clear even what it is
that's my advice
all right let's talk for just a couple
minutes about pairs before we sign off
absolutely of course
um there's an account on Twitter a guy
named Paul Ferry who is apparently a
researcher at University of Calgary Who
does these sort of long historic threads
with pieces from newspapers uh and uh in
recently he's done one on the correct
way to eat various fruits historical
accounts of the correct way to eat
various fruits and he's got an 1863 and
it's it's fun it's good he's got an 1863
quotation from Henry Henry Ward
feature uh
that includes the following
let me see
a few people untrained by palmological
conventions know how to eat pears
they take them after a hearty meal they
take whole ones they eat them should
their selection be good they are
fortunate if bad they must eat the whole
or give up
Gather in your friends at evening the
tea is taken in a mere souvenir of bread
now while all are fresh unstuffed and
unsated bring in your pears seven or
eight kinds let one man carve take the
probably poorest first and yet your
poorest must be good
give to each guest a section of the same
pair
eat together from the one fruit and be
United and magnetized by the spiritual
essence of the one fruit
so on from fruit to fruit and from kind
to kind thus each one without cloying or
over fullness will have tasted of each
kind and of every specimen
meantime the conversation must abound
tell the great and wonderful stories of
the new seedling of the wonderful yield
of the immense size of the Freaks and
fantasies of luck and unlock in this or
that sort in short have a real Garden
gossip pear is thus discriminately and
unselfishly eaten will prove to be not
the forbidden fruit
that's marvelous isn't that marvelous
yeah and it felt it felt apropos this
week of Thanksgiving American
Thanksgiving
uh where there is we hope that all of
you in the United States who celebrate
American holidays have have taken of
much wonderful food this week and have
much to be grateful for and have shared
that with your family and and friends
who was gathered who were gathered with
you but I will say the particular
description of how it is to share pairs
as he's talking about matches very much
what very often oh boy is the dog gonna
sit on the couch or
um
the dressage section of the podcast has
begun
um
what I think very often it's been you
and Toby oh and it's more often with
apples than with pears sometimes it's
mangoes uh we'll bring to the table
often it's not our entire meal you see
it's after dinner we'll bring a cutting
board and several apples and you will
cut and share and we will talk and we
will each have a bit of an apple and
some you know it might seem that you
know having been given a piece of an
apple that isn't so good like I don't
want anywhere that one just went like no
for sharing the Apple
maybe we can all decide that that one
isn't worth eating and we can get rid of
it but you learn so much about food and
about individual variation not just in
the food itself but in yourselves when
you do it this way as well it's it's
remarkable and it really is I mean it's
it's breaking fruit not breaking bread
but it's it's that yeah and it's it's
marvelous too because the
nobody knows how to make a great apple
right what we can do is take a tree that
makes a great apple and we can propagate
its branches by grafting them to things
or whatever but yeah the individual
variation apples are so far from
breeding true they just right and this
is true within a lot of fruits that you
know a particular tree yields especially
delay and I had this experience in in
Panama when I was doing my bat work I
actually had a a license to operate very
tiny boats in the Panama Canal and I
used to go to some of the abandoned
mango trees that existed in the Canal
Zone because the panamanians abandoned
meaning that they had been planted for
their fruit bearing capacity absolutely
they had been planted and were now
abandoned because
citizens were driven out of the Canal
Zone when the canal was put in and it
was basically maintained as a human-free
Zone
and so they're all of these trees
and some of them would give you these
watery stringy mangoes that weren't
worth eating and some of them would give
you just the most incredibly delightful
you know sweet and uh complex and that
was uh by tree like in trees were
reliable yes they were and so a
particularly good tree fruiting in a
particular place would have me go back
there regularly yeah planning like a
common hummingbird exactly exactly but
anyways don't eat mangoes but
they would have trouble that's trouble
with that but
um but there is something amazing the
subtlety of the difference between one
apple to the next sometimes even within
you know if you go to the market and you
buy a particular strain of Apple but you
still get one that's okay and one that's
delightful and totally you know the
notes are very subtle and so anyway it
is kind of a cool experience you don't
you typically have an apple or somebody
else as an apple you don't share within
an apple but it does bring you together
you know what and here you're saying
don't do that don't treat your fruit
that way don't a whole apple and just
eat it to yourself what's that point
yeah no you and and you know there's a
question about why we don't do this with
lots of things right like you know like
a hamburger
wasn't on my lips but it shouldn't be
um but sorry you know we sort of do this
with cheese
right a board of cheese that one's
particularly good yeah
um and because you know even you always
came from the same uh from Marjorie like
it you know well but this one didn't
ripen as well this one like this one is
not as good as the last time I had that
wheel right the the same wheel it's not
the same but we should do it it varies
with wine
in other words I think far more
interesting than the elite bottle of
wine is the distinction between bottles
that aren't so Elite but that you could
yeah it's hard to do if there's just you
know two of you and you aren't
alcoholics right exactly because it
doesn't say it but if you have if you
have a party right yeah yeah you know
tasting a little bit of this and a
little bit of that rather than large
glasses of whatever yeah is more
interesting and also I mean flights
right like tasting flights are are all
the rage now in foodie circles or lots
of things and you know food to some
degree but you know cider flights wine
flights cocktail flights Spirit flights
yeah buddy the idea of sharing them and
adding the social component yeah you
know if two people have a mirrored
flight of something then you know
discussing what the individual things
taste like to them which may be
different for reasons of physiology or
probably developmentally different or
whatever is is interesting interesting
stuff and I also you know I don't drink
beer anymore as you know because uh
wheat right I can't drink it um but I
always liked beer better than Wine
because the
it was much more about variance than
Precision right the vast array of
different flavors and different beers
is I think in some ways more interesting
than so seriously one show you're going
to take on the the Bigfoot crowd and the
wine crowd I I just I feel like there's
probably relatively small overlap
between the two so you know you've got
two pretty you know pretty powerful
lobbies coming after us the uh the
Bigfoot the Bigfoot folks I don't think
they're big wine drinkers that's that's
yeah yeah that's what I was trying to
communicate yeah yeah that's uh I think
that's likely yes so yes now we have we
can add those to the list of people who
count us as enemies I guess because
you've claimed that wine doesn't have
the variation for the palette that beer
does that's what I heard you say it's
more a level of refinement than it is a
matter of variance yeah there's there's
a there's a broader Spectrum for beer
yeah that's is that it that's that's my
claim okay yep you heard it here
all right so anyone else we can offend
oh I'm sure I'm sure okay the dog is
gonna break something we better get off
here before she does so
she's wondering why she gave up her spot
she'll never get it back now
um
all right well that was the first of
four live streams that we're gonna be
doing this weekend uh hang out where you
are right now if you're listening live
and we'll be back in about 15 minutes
with a q a we're going to start with
three count them three questions from
the Discord server because every week
they vote on a question they really want
us to answer and because we missed our
last two q and A's uh we've got three
from them this week but you can go to
darkhorsesmissions.com to ask a question
we will not get to all of them but we
will get to as many as we can and then
tomorrow but in the 15-minute break that
they have this would be a great time to
stretch their knees whether they are
simulated uh real or imaginary yeah your
certainty in your neededness should not
affect whether or not you can stretch
them
right they need stretching one way or
the other that I think we can safely say
totally Oh see now they're missing all
the carnivorous action happening down
here at this point well we'll we'll get
back as soon as possible and see if we
can replicate some of this
um you we encourage you to join our
patreons tomorrow uh at 9 45 a.m Pacific
we're gonna do a one hour like holiday
gift episode of Dark Horse and then take
another 15 minute break and then come
into our private q a available through
my patreon and next weekend from 9 to 11
Pacific on each of the weekend days
Brett will be having some of his
conversations on patreon so please
consider going over to
patreon.com and finding one or both of
our accounts there and joining us there
until we see you next be good to the
ones you love eat good food and get
outside and fight the simulators
[Music]